look seriously there's a reason he's
called the great one that was a tour de
force from FDR betraying Central Europe
right up through Khrushchev and Kennedy
let me share with you an anecdote from
just a few hours ago I was coming out of
a hotel in Washington and somebody comes
up to me and shouts you're a fascist and
I said come over here let's talk and I
said so why am i fascist because you
worked for Donald Trump that's about as
deep as the analysis gets they are in an
utter bubble I want to make one comment
on the Helsinki hysteria for the last 70
years 70 years Moscow has been trying to
undermine our democracy including our
elections but it only became an issue
for the left and the media now why Sean
because Donald Trump won the election
they didn't care for the last 70 years
from water Durante right up to john
brennan who voted for the Communist
Party before he joined the CIA they
didn't care they only care now because
they want to undermine the integrity of
that election and because they wanted
Hillary to win what the only reason